hi I'm Jennifer Coolidge and I'm with
BuzzFeed and I'm gonna be reading my
first tweets where I got a good one to
begin with but just want to put this out
there Jennifer Coolidge is a con thank
you Gary
she has enough big energy to power a
small town that's the nicest thing
anyone's ever said to me her frickin
name is Jennifer Coolidge melt yeah just
as that movie not not because of real
life I don't really have any children
I was barren anyway um I miss Jennifer
Coolidge lol she looked so good and was
funny as I'm not dead you know she
worried I sure miss Jennifer Coolidge
I'm gonna leave this tweet on her grave
oh this is kind of flattering my ex
didn't know who Jennifer Coolidge was
and that should have been a sign right
yeah that's if they don't know I am just
dump them where the because Jennifer
Coolidge Ben I love that thing
Thank You JC oh this is very nice you
know yeah stars born was pretty good but
you know what performance was Academy
award-winning Jennifer Coolidge as Fiona
Montgomery and for those of you didn't
know that was a Cinderella story with
Hilary Duff my sexual identity as
Jennifer Coolidge in Legally Blonde and
then he acts it out with a bunch of
stick figures
I hope des is single because he said
Jennifer Coolidge is so sexy well I hope
I meet you one day day I just want
Jennifer Coolidge to slap me with a
purse thank you
I will oh you know what this is the
nicest thing anyone has ever said
Jennifer Coolidge made me gay I don't
know how to take this Jennifer Coolidge
has been that big since day one and this
one I can't get it out but it says
Jennifer Coolidge has buck teeth
that's kind of mean I guess I should you
know look at my Twitter more I'm
Jennifer Coolidge and I just read my
first tweets I got one last one left you
should go see like a boss on January 10
bye bye
[Music]